social media is one of the most powerful
tools in human history for building your
influence whether you want to grow a
business grow a brand grow a non-profit
or just build a side hustle or get a
message out to the world social media is
the way to do it these platforms are
free and recent stats revealed that over
half of the world's total population are
now active on social media that is crazy
but here's the thing social media also
has a big weakness and that is that you
don't control the platforms whether it's
Facebook Instagram or YouTube algorithms
are always changing you might post one
video or image today that reaches tons
of your followers and then tomorrow all
of a sudden that reach has been cut in
half or has been messed with in some way
so what's the answer well you have to be
building an email list sometimes email
lists are not the most sexy thing in the
world but yet they are still the
foundation of building a real online
business with the ability to communicate
with your audience on your own terms and
in this video we're actually going to be
breaking down 7 tips of how to build
your email list and some secrets that
we've use to build an email list of over
280,000 people plus some multiple
seven-figure business so get ready
buckle your seat belt because it's
coming up alright now in the think
marketing podcast
welcome to the big marketing podcast the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm shawn kennel
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you hey
what's up Sean kennel here and welcome
back to the think marketing podcast
where we are obsessed with helping you
build a high impact and high profit
online business leveraging social media
and video but here's the thing I
actually don't believe that it's
possible to build a predictably
profitable online business without
building an email list I know it's not
the coolest thing to talk about we want
to get more social media followers we
want to get more social media likes we
want more reach on our posts and we're
obsessed with those things here at the
think marketing podcasts because those
things matter to getting more awareness
getting more exposure but if you want to
build a predictably profitable online
business you got to be building your
email list and that's what today's
session is all about this session is
actually brought to you by our inner
circle program that's our monthly
business and marketing membership that
we have here at our hole think media
brand and this session is taught by
Heather Taurus the chief operation
officer of think media and she's
actually going to be breaking down seven
elements of an irresistible freemium so
what was the secret for us growing our
email list to over two hundred and
eighty three thousand subscribers by the
way we've probably grown our email lists
to over seven hundred thousand in the
journey of our various brands and
businesses and what you do is from time
to time you clean your email list if
people haven't been opening emails or
maybe the emails are being delivered to
junk or they're going somewhere else
you you narrow that down I think right
now we have something like 350 thousand
active email subscribers well how have
we done that what is the secret to doing
that it's irresistible freemium well
Shawn what is a freemium well there's a
couple different words for it
when is the lead magnet as a business
owner you need leads people that have
raised their hand to say I'm interested
in the category the topic the products
the services that your business offers
and so I'm gonna give you my contact
information in exchange for some in spur
a lead magnet right and that could be
anything it could be a checklist we've
done those that thick media it could be
an hour-long webinar we have those here
at thick media right now it could be you
know an mp3 audio series or just an
audio file or like a video training it
also could be there's a lot of different
lead magnets or freemium 's we call them
freemium that's free premium content
it's gonna help you get a result it's
gonna help the listener the viewer the
person who downloads it solve a specific
problem and so in exchange for their
information other people call them free
freebies another one is content upgrades
it's a free gift other people call them
ethical bribes like it's a way to say
hey I'm gonna give you something really
cool as a way I'm giving you some really
cool free premium information in
exchange for the ability to keep
communicating with you to see if you
potentially would want to do business
down the road right and so that's what a
freemium is and in this session
Heather Taurus breaks down seven
elements of how to have listened an
irresistible freemium because this is
the critical element you know on blogs
they call them content upgrades you know
you read a little bit of free
information on the blog you watched some
really good free information on the
YouTube video but now I want a content
upgrade I want to go deeper and give me
something that's organized you know
something that is that I can take home
or digest maybe a mini ebook definitely
not a log log E but book you want a
quick result for that viewer and that
listener so that's what today's session
is all about so get ready you might want
to grab a pen grab a journal because
Heather breaks down some really powerful
content that you're gonna love and
that's gonna help you either grow an
email list from scratch or if you
already have one you lean in even more
because this is gonna help you grow your
email list faster with listen the right
people for your bit
business your brand the right audience
that you want to attract lean in because
that's all coming up right now on the
think marketing podcast you're going to
jump into how are you going to build
your profitable email list with a high
value freemium that's what we're gonna
cover right now so here's the the first
thing I like to say yes it's a high
value freemium but we want to actually
create an irresistible freemium so I'm
gonna share with you the seven elements
of an irresistible freemium and you know
to me um this is really important
because as we go through this we're
gonna set some goals we're going to
create your first freemium
by the end of this we are going to
update your current freemium so like
Sean said if you are already at this I
saw someone in the chat said I already
have freemium is going already have
digital courses that's great I want to
challenge you you know we are building a
multi-million dollar business right now
we have more freemium to create like
Sean said I have a list sitting over
here that I'm so excited to get started
on so we're gonna update our current
premiums and we're gonna create
additional premiums to the business so
no matter where you're starting whether
you're just starting at the beginning or
if you are moving towards a higher level
scale freemium are the best way to
exchange with your your your people who
are going to become your customers
because here's the thing a freemium a
lead magnet a web class whatever you
want to call it this is a gift this is a
gift because when someone is going to
move from the space of following you to
exchanging their information with you
that's a gift and here in inner circle
we hold that as a very high value if
someone is willing to give us their
personal information their email address
they're saying I want to at some point
do business with you it is so important
that we value this as a gift so don't
just think of it as I just need to build
an email list and you to build this
thing every single person on that email
list is a person
like let's think about that every single
person on your email list they are a
real person who has real needs and real
problems and they need your help the
first part of the seven elements of
irresistible freemium this is what we're
gonna create we're gonna walk through
this it needs to solve a problem the
freemium itself needs to solve a problem
so I'm gonna show you some big mistakes
that content creators that entrepreneurs
make and mistakes we personally have
made in creating freemium x' and this is
the first one it has to actually solve a
problem this is so important if you're
just putting information out into the
world if it doesn't actually hit a pain
point for a person there's no reason
that they should actually want to do
business with you so number number one
is it needs to solve a problem so when
you're creating a freemium the question
you want to ask yourself is what problem
does this pre does this freemium solve
write it out what is the actual problem
that's number one number two one piece
of the puzzle so one of the seven
elements of an irresistible freemium is
it needs to solve one piece of the
puzzle now another big mistake is on
entrepreneurs will create freemium that
solve every single problem and let me
tell you that's not where your audience
needs to start so for us it is not it is
not a good idea to create a freemium
that is going to solve the world's
problems through video that is not where
we need to start we need to start all
the way back at the beginning of how do
you start a youtube channel that's a
piece of the puzzle of online business
so that's how you would solve it that's
number two so the question you ask
yourself is what is one piece of the
puzzle that this premium
solves number three the freemium needs
to be easy and quick to digest the
freemium needs to be easy and quick to
digest this is so important because we
want people to get a quick win and when
I say easy I mean easy for not just
desktop but also mobile cuz look at this
in 2018 mobile devices made up
42% of the total time spent online
I mean raise your hand in your own room
wherever you are right now raise your
hand if you spend more time on your
mobile device than you do your desktop
now I'm not talking for work-wise I mean
like just for entertainment or you're
researching do you use your mobile
device or do you use your desktop
well this survey from similarweb said
42% of time is spent online which means
your premium it actually needs to be
able to be quickly consumed through a
mobile device so when you're creating
premiums you do not want them to be
filled with a ton of graphics that could
you know they have to scroll over to the
right or to the left or that you make a
video that doesn't isn't designed in a
webpage that is allowing for it to be
mobile-friendly so when you're thinking
about the freemium that you're doing to
make it irresistible for someone to
consume it needs to be quick and easy
number four it needs to have a high
value now this is I just want to take a
pause for a second because this is where
so many entrepreneurs fall into this
mistake they just want to get something
out there right you're like I just want
to make something and I want to get it
out there really quick here's the thing
if this is the first time that someone
is going to exchange information with
you if this is the first time that a
person who has a need and you're on the
other end with an answer this is the
first time they're gonna interact with
you and it doesn't bring high value to
them what do you think that says about
your business like what do you think
that is that that person is gonna think
the next time they're looking for a dog
trainer or the next time they want to
organize their kitchen or the next time
they're looking for a homeschool mom to
help them like what is it gonna say if
the thing that you're creating creating
doesn't give them high value and so this
doesn't mean that it needs to be you
know a large premium this just means
that it needs to cut right to the pain
point of your audience and be able to
serve them at a high capacity for free
like free like all the information
you're gonna put in there is going to be
information that they could take action
on and
and actually see results so let's jump
into the next one here I switch back
over alright so number 5 it means that
in the ability to instantly be
accessible so a lot of times what can
happen with a freemium is that uh with
with deliverability of different
freemium 's people will make people wait
to get it and that is not going to look
great on your brand this is something
that needs to be easily accessible so
for us in our business we go from
landing page to asking for their email
to directly to the freemium because we
want you to have it to be a seamless
process as you're going through so the
question you need to ask yourself is is
this freemium easy to it to be consumed
as easily easily accessible and a great
way to test this out is to send the
webpage to like five of your closest
friends and say hey how easy is this
like are you able to do this how easy is
that for you number six it needs to
deliver are i a results in advance this
is so critical because a lot of times in
business we want to hold back we don't
want to give the way the good stuff for
free and here's what we need to do as
business owners we need to be open
handed and we need to allow our
potential customers to see that we're
able to get results for them in advance
so when they're downloading your
freemium when they're listening to your
audio when they are watching your video
could they never do business with you
and have their life changed that's what
I want you to think about if this person
were to never do business with me and
all they have is all the freemium that
I'm created would their life be changed
and I want you to always say yes to that
answer the last one is in these to give
a clear call to action so these are the
seven elements of creating an
irresistible freemium it needs to give a
clear call to action here's a big
mistake that can happen with a lot of
premiums is that it doesn't tell the
person the next step to take with you
you know if they've just invested five
minutes 10 minutes an hour into their
time with you what's the next thing they
should do should they follow you on
social media to be able to get more tips
exactly like this should they should
they move into your course if the next
thing you're selling is an online
digital product should they buy
something that you have that's physical
what is the next call to action that
that person should have with you now as
we go through this I want to show you
these are the big mistakes to avoid and
sorry Shawn I'm gonna actually use your
first premium that you created as the
biggest mistakes to avoid so the first
thing is this ebook it was way too long
for a freemium you know Shawn was newer
in the market and so he was creating
something that he had already had access
to which is great but it's not gonna be
an irresistible freemium for someone
when the second is is it's not really
easy to consume I mean yes it was easy
it was accessible and so he clicked that
box but is it very easy to consume I
mean a lot of people don't actually want
to read through an e-book they would
rather have a one page or a two page
checklist to be able to do that so this
is going through Shawn's premium and the
third is this actually solved more than
one piece of the puzzle I mean he was
saying like how to use social media to
grow your brand and reach more people
now if he was super specific to that
puzzle he could have a freemium for
Instagram and Facebook and YouTube and
he could be really really specific on
what type of reach you could expect and
how long it would take so that kind of
walks you through the seven elements of
an irresistible freemium needs to solve
our problem it needs to be one piece of
the puzzle needs to be easy and quick to
digest it needs to be high value so that
your brand is representative high value
needs to be instantly accessible it
needs to deliver results in advanced and
you need to give a clear call-to-action
for where the person should go next so
here's an example I saw this one online
it was from digital marketer and I mean
look at this look at this copy look at
this headline grow enough food to feed a
family of four in just four square feet
of space even if you don't have a yard
now if you are interested in in
gardening and your
pain point is you want to learn how to
do a garden but you don't have any yard
space there you go there's your freemium
right there you get instant access to
this to this guide my next one here is
from Amy Porterfield she's giving out a
free checklist a cheat sheet I'm sorry
she's giving out a free cheat sheet that
gives you 20 smart strategies to help
you grow your email list uh if I'm
trying to grow an email list and my pain
point is that I definitely want to know
what the 20 smart strategies are right I
don't want to be you know going through
different strategies and not knowing if
they're the right ones and then check
this one out this is a meal plan get
five free meal plans free only five very
easy to consume it's not overwhelming
you're not taking on an entire diet book
but you're able to get five free meal
plans to to test drive to see is this
person going to be able to help me in
the future when I'm ready to exchange
money with someone in the in a few in
the future will this person be able to
help me and this one is a great idea for
that so let's jump into seven easy to
create freemium because I saw a lot of
comments that we're coming through about
not knowing what type of freedoms to
create and you know if you're just
starting I want you to pick one off of
these off of this list off of these
seven and if you've been in business for
a while and you don't have all seven of
these well I'm gonna challenge you to
look into creating these seven
irresistible freemium these are easy to
create free means you can create a
checklist templates an audio recording a
video training calendars cheat sheets a
plan a planner or printables these are
the ones inner circle that we're going
to start with this month we're gonna
choose one off of this list we're gonna
use our knowledge and we're going to
create something right off of this list
so here are some examples for you to
kind of get those wheels going for you
so uh Marie Forleo she has a youtube
show and she sells a Academy and online
Academy and that's the only two things
she really does in her business she's
very focused and so to supplement that
and create a freemium she decided to
create an audio free
because that was easiest for her to move
her clients or to move people into
becoming clients getting into their ears
being someone that could speak to them
that is exactly what she was looking for
and then life is messy planners she
creates free planners now she also
creates some where you can purchase them
and get them sent to your home so you
don't to print them out and but the
freemium is that you can download
different printables for free and then
we have a free master class that's a
video training is a very simple landing
page that we created and then again Amy
Porter fields on there as well here's
some other examples for you free
five-day declutter challenge stop
letting clutter weigh you down in five
days you will see a difference in your
home that is an amazing freemium that
can be delivered through an email
sequence that can be through a checklist
that maybe they download and it's every
day or that could be a video series that
you're walking them through the Kumari
checklist that's one that I personally
downloaded myself and I put this on here
because that is hitting a trend and that
helps if you are someone who is in the
organizing space
what about workout schedule or what
about an eating plan or what about a
video content calendar whatever you are
doing in your audience I'm sure you can
figure out a calendar or a schedule or a
checklist that can go along with it and
I just wanted to share with you you know
while I was putting my part of the
presentation together I was searching
around on different websites and I got
hit with this this is a freemium that I
got hit with when I was researching list
building I was just trying to you know
get some ideas to give to you guys
beyond what we have created here I think
media and look at this get my five-day
email funnel that generated four hundred
thousand dollars from a single launch uh
yeah I think I'd like that because I'm
in the market right now of searching how
to build email lists so look at what
happened he created this irresistible
freemium for me then he asked me to
confirm my email which was very easy to
do and then right there after I
confirmed my email this is sitting on
the next page so I clicked on it sent me
right to the next page and boom and
guess what it only
took me ten minutes to read through ten
minutes
I learned five days of emails in ten
minutes and now I can take that and I
can put it into our business if I find
that that was useful and I did I read
through what growth lab had and I was
like wow I don't even know who growth
lab is but now I'm gonna start following
them so guess what I did after that and
went to social media and I was like huh
I wonder if they have a YouTube channel
and then I was like I wonder if I should
follow them on Facebook wonder what kind
of content they create on Facebook now
I'm not a customer of theirs yet but do
you see how now I'm inside of their
world
I went from getting into a freemium to
now following them on social media to
then watching to see what will the offer
be I mean if it's a valuable offer for
me I probably will buy it because I got
so much value out of this ten minutes of
their free Mia so we went through the
seven irresistible elements - oh sorry
the seven elements of an irresistible
freemium we just went through different
types of freemium that you can create
and now we're going to go through the
five steps to creating an irresistible
freemium in under 30 days can you commit
to that inner circle creating a freemium
in under 30 days now I know if you're
anything like me you're like okay yeah
that sounds great because I'm a consumer
I love being on web classes and reading
through premiums and doing all the
things like Sean said um it is so much
easier to post on Instagram that it is
to create a freemium and I will
definitely tell you that even for my own
personal brand and and for my
homeschooling channel I only have one
freemium I mean I teach this for a
living and I only have one freemium and
here's why because unless you commit to
doing it like unless you make the
commitment and you publicly say like I'm
gonna make this freemium and I'm gonna
plan out the time to do it and I'm gonna
walk through the freemium creation
checklist doesn't get done I mean if we
can be honest it doesn't get done and so
we want to challenge each other we want
to uplift each other we want to be there
to be able to help each other get
through this first step because you know
what this does
this search to build an email list and
then you know what happens after that
you start to gain some confidence
because you're like wow I created this
and people are using it and then you
know what you do you start to actually
talk to your customer or your potential
customers and you're like hey did you
guys like this did you want something
else like this or if they email you back
and they're like this was so great but
what about this and you're like ah
wonder what my next freemium should be
about right and the whole cycle starts
and I think one thing that's hard for
new business owners to really grasp the
concept of is that this is pretty simple
like it really is simple
you create something that you think your
target audience will want you solve a
problem and then you ask them what would
you like next what's the next thing that
you would like you know the entire
reason that video ranking Academy was
burst was because we knew that that is
what a massive audience was looking for
and we knew that because we asked them
and so if you're like curious what
should my first bring me a beer
what kind of checklist should I make or
well you know what type of audio would
they like to hear I guarantee you that
the current audience you have whether
it's one person or 1 million people they
will tell you exactly what their pain
point is if you ask them so first you
need to decide what are you gonna create
so we have that list right we had the
seven things on the list are you gonna
create a checklist a template an audio
recording a video training are you gonna
create a calendar a cheat sheet or a
planner or a printable you just circle
it you just decide what am I gonna
create the next thing you're gonna do is
you're gonna create your outline now
this outline here me inner circle this
is where we love to get stuck right cuz
we're like oh my gosh I could put all
this in it I don't mind I kept it all
this in it and I could just I just go
crazy but here's what I want you to
remember what we did on our first
freemium roadmap is we need to decide
what's the one pain point I mean if you
really know your stuff like if you know
that there is someone you can help with
the information you're putting out there
if you and I were to go to coffee you
would
know what my pain point is I mean we
know it here at think media we know
exactly the pain points that our
customers have and so we're gonna create
freemium surround that here's what we do
we started to create the outline and we
take like ten days to create the outline
because that actually stops us from
actually doing the hard stuff which is
the the tech right it actually stops us
from putting something out there and
feeling like well what if no one likes
this or like what if no one downloads
this but here's the thing I want you to
commit to spending an hour or less
creating your outline that's it an hour
or less that's all I want you to do and
on your paper on your printable it says
I will spend blank hours working on my
outline and then it says I will complete
my outline on this day I think it's
powerful when we write down our goals
and we write down our dates and we look
at our calendar and we really actually
commit to ourselves to taking action
that's where we start to see
transformation take place and so you're
gonna decide what you're going to create
you're going to create your outline and
then the next thing we'll do is we're
gonna actually create the freemium
that's right you're gonna create the
freemium you're going to create the
checklist you're going to record the
audio you're going to film that video
you're going to do whatever it is that
you need to do and here's where we get
stuck again so right it's oh man Heather
this is so hard I don't know what to do
or how to make it or what it looks like
or you know what that could be but I
want you to know that there is so much
information online that can help you
through this so if you're like I really
want to create you know a checklist and
I just don't know how I'll bet gia that
on YouTube or on Google there's someone
who's walked you through it on canva or
I'll bet that there's someone inside of
inner circle we have hundreds of smart
purpose-driven entrepreneurs here inside
of inner circle leverage them and say
how do I do this
how do you make a freemium in canva does
anyone have a template that they've use
or hey what do you guys think is the
best way to upload audio has anyone done
that before and there is so much
information here inside of this group of
individuals that don't let creating the
freemium be your blocker don't let you
getting something out into the world be
the the blocker right here the creating
of the freemium be that blocker for you
so you're gonna commit to creating your
freemium and then on the sheet before
you can check that off I will complete
my freemium on this day what day is it
you've got 30 days to get this done what
day in the next 30 days are you going to
commit to doing it the next is you need
tools sorry let me go through oh sorry
went to guess you need tools for
delivery so what are the tools that you
need for delivery actually delivering
your freemium to your potential clients
do the people that are opting in well
here's the three things that you need
this is all you need you need a landing
page which means that is the page that
you collect their emails from you need
an email service provider and you
actually need the freemium I know I had
to put that on there number three is
actually delivering the freemium now
there are so many ways that you can do
this and if you are a serious
entrepreneur and you're ready to go to
the level that is going to grow your
business and you want an all in one
solution Sean already told you we use
kajabi we use kajabi because it can be
heard to link this together and put that
in here and use this email per service
writer and do these things go together
and how does this deliver here in that
and that if you just commit to something
that is an investment into your business
you're going to make the things happen
that are going to get you to the next
level in your business and so we use
kajabi for several reasons one it has
everything we mean the landing pages the
email service provider it has the places
that we can use for hosting of our
downloads and our videos and our audios
and all the O's we use kajabi for that
and you know I want you to know too that
if you're boots
like if you're just starting out if
you're like Heather there is no way I'm
gonna commit to something that is like
that like I can't do that yet no worries
because we've all started in a
bootstrapping season and so some other
options besides using um kajabi are
things like MailChimp that's where Sean
started you know he started on MailChimp
because that let him collect emails you
could start Squarespace that's a website
provider but depending on what package
you have with them you're able to
collect emails and deliver deliverables
to people and then there's also wicks
and Wix is another easy email provider
to be able to do that and I can tell you
I have had experience with all of these
all four of these I've also used think
if ik and and I've used teachable I've
used so many different pieces of
software and I can tell you that one of
the easiest things is being able to use
software that does it for you I mean
unless you're someone who wants to
actually learn how to do all the things
and connect everything together and
figure out you know oh I can only
collect this mini email addresses or I
can only do so much here I need to do a
lot more the branding or whatever the
triggers are for you that's why we use
kajabi but all of these are just a way
to start and that's what we need you to
do we need you to pick a way that you're
gonna deliver your freemium and you just
need to start and you can start on one
of these and eventually move to
something else but you need a way that
you can deliver your landing pages have
an email service provider and then
deliver the freemium to your potential
customers and then lastly you need to
have three emails for follow-up and this
is critical because if we're not able to
communicate with the people who have
opted into our world we are wasting the
opportunity to grow in relationship with
that person now hear me out
inner circle here today I said I didn't
say we're wasting the opportunity to
sell them something I didn't say that
you are wasting the opportunity to build
a relationship because we hear an inner
circle we are not
about the quick buck we are about the
long game we are about helping you
create a business and Empire a structure
that will give you freedom and so when
you're actually starting to build this
part of your business you need to start
emailing and here's what happens we send
one email and you know that feels like
after you've only got one email you're
like wow that's that's it that's all I'm
worth to you one email no follow-up no
no asking me questions no no starting a
relationship I mean that's it I mean
cool I got my I got my piece I got what
I needed out of it but you don't want to
go deeper with me you don't wanna know
my problems are I mean I actually said I
raised my hand and said I have this
problem that's why I'm downloading your
thing and you don't want to go further I
mean that's how I I don't know how you
feel about that but I can tell you that
if I had these three things here it
would make me feel a lot better about
the business that I'm going into and so
number one is you need a confirmation
email there are records right now in
email open rates with this specific
email a confirmation email up to words
of 80 percent of open rates from an
email that says here's your confirmation
that is amazing that is an opportunity
right there in their inbox to speak to
your potential clients and customers
number two is a follow-up email did you
get this now let me know if you can
relate inner circle you have been doing
something on your phone you're like deep
in research you're all excited you're
like ooh I want that yeah I'm gonna do
that okay yeah oh I'm gonna watch that
women are oh yeah okay I'm gonna
definitely follow through this checklist
I'm gonna print it out I'm gonna do all
those things then it goes inge and
you're like ooh Instagram
oh she leans life I should watch that
too and then all of a sudden you didn't
actually consume the content and so a
follow-up email that can come anywhere
from four hours to 24 hours later that
actually says hey I know life gets crazy
and busy and you can speak to them in
whatever tone or language or whatever
would make sense to you so for me let's
say it's my homeschool channel I could
say something like hey I know that
homeschooling can take up a lot of your
time and you know a lot of times the
kids can be a distraction but I just
wanted to make
sure did you happen to listen to the
full audio I recommend that next time
you're doing laundry plug that bad boy
in so you can get all the way through it
and it's just a follow up and I'm
speaking to her and we're just being
friends right we're just talking I'm
starting this relationship it's kind of
a volley back and forth and then the
last is a next step or feedback now this
is critical inner circle to ask your
customers your absorption customers the
people on your email list hey did you
like this is really important because
this is where you're going to get the
actual information about what you should
change because let me tell you like Sean
said your first premiums they're
probably not gonna be your best frames I
will raise my hand right now and say
that the freemium that I have on my
website don't go to it cuz it's awful
don't go to it right now but the
freemium that I have on my home school
site right now it could be better and
you know how I could figure out if it
could be better if I just asked the 500
people who have downloaded it hey did
you like this was there anything missing
did you consume all of it how long did
it take you to get through this hey what
is your next step
that is valuable information and you
know what it does it lets down this
barrier of me being on this like weird
pedestal that we put people on and it
brings me back down to hey I'm here I'm
here for you I want to help you I want
to know what your struggles are I want
you to know that I'm a little bit
further on the path and I just want to
help and so just let me know like hey
did you like this or did you want
something different or would you love a
video that supports that like these are
critical questions to ask your audience
so when you're going through these are
the three emails that I'd love you to
commit to making and guess what inner
circle we're gonna give you templates
for all three of these emails we're
gonna just swipe copy our actual emails
so that you're able to just plug in what
works for you and then you can just send
those emails in automation with whatever
service provider you have gone to so
let's move through that again the five
steps to creating this irresistible
freemium in one we get
less or in 30 days which is what we've
committed to but if you do it on a
weekend awesome
here you go you're gonna decide what
you're going to create you're gonna
create your outline you're gonna create
the freemium itself you're gonna create
the tools for delivery and then you're
gonna set up three emails for follow up
that's we're gonna do inner circle and I
just want to walk you through this you
know this is what it can kind of feel
like I don't know about you but my three
kids eleven how old are they now eleven
ten and seven are obsessed with Legos I
mean we have Legos I feel like we should
buy stock in Legos because we have so
many it's just something that we really
love to use in educational way and this
right here is representation of all of
the pieces of your business you know
when you get a Lego set you like go to
the store and they're so excited they're
like jumping up and down because you
bought this Lego set for them and they
get it home and they rip open the
package and my organization mind is like
OMG that is a lot of little pieces I
what are we gonna do with this and then
they start building right it's like one
at a time and they go through the book
and they're just putting one piece on
top of the other on top of the other but
here's the thing
your freemium it is just one piece of
the puzzle
your freemium is where we need to start
this is the starting point and then over
time as you're working through your
manual as you're going through inner
circle as you're leaning on the
community here and as you start to build
this business you're gonna create
something magnificent you're gonna
create this awesome
Lego castle I mean look how much energy
and excitement and intricacy is inside
of this castle there's there's people
involved which is team and there's
leaves growing which means that it's
aged and there's this gigantic building
and you look back and you're like wow I
started with this and first I built this
and now I've built this and so our goal
for you inner circle is to create your
first freemium our goal for you inner
circle that if you are
advanced is to update your current
premiums go through these actual
downloads and say Wow am i solving five
pain points or am i solving one Wow are
they able to get actual results with
this in the time that I think they
should well I need to change that or you
need to create additional premiums
because there are more people out there
who need exactly what you have to offer
so those were the seven elements of an
irresistible freemium but stick around
because we've got a lot of great content
still to come on the think marketing
podcast this week but if you've been
getting value out of this session and
you're listening or watching this on
youtube hit the like button and question
of the day for just your journal or for
the comments section below is what
freemium do you need to create next
applying and taking action on the seven
elements of an irresistible freemium
from Heather what freemium can you
improve or what freemium can you make
next drop that in the comments write
that in your journal and remember we
take massive action here at the think
marketing podcast because that's where
the results are and I want to remind you
that this session was just a small piece
of one of the monthly sessions in our
inner circle program and if you want to
learn more about that you can go to
think inner circle com
what inner circle is is it's our
exclusive monthly program where we teach
you step by step everything that we've
learned from growing a seven-figure
media company online and what's working
right now to dominate with social media
and video what we actually do is once a
month we do an hour-long session that
was a piece of one of the full sessions
where we'll talk about the latest and
most important topics in growing an
online business
we have other training like video
ranking Academy that focuses on YouTube
but the real question is it's kind of
like the iceberg right YouTube or social
media it's just the tip of the iceberg
but below that come on it's about
building a product or an offer what's
your sales process what are you doing to
market online are you when are you ready
for Facebook Ads and doing digital
marketing how's your branding what's
your overall messaging what's your
polarizing point of view and these are
the types of topics we talk about
inner circle it's all the stuff that
we've learned that is beneath the
surface behind the brand if you will of
just the front end content that you see
on our main YouTube channel think media
and so if you've loved this content I
want to invite you to join the program
every single month we go live for an
hour talking about the latest online
BART marketing and online business tips
and strategies and then we also do an
hour of hot seats and Q&A so you get
some insider access there's a private
Facebook group that we do and probably
one of the coolest things that people
love is the activating worksheets every
month so every worksheet you get an
action plan so that you can put the tips
into action with some bonus resources
and things and you get access to the
vault so when you're an inner circle
member which is an ability to join
monthly or to just pay for one year at a
time and save a little bit we give you
access to the vault so you get the past
sessions and we've covered this was
actually part of a three-part session
about building getting building your
email list so how do you create an
irresistible freemium grow your email
list then how do you actually create an
online product and online course but a
mini course like in a weekend like
quickly creating a course so you have
something to sell related to your
YouTube channel your brand your business
and then how do you market that online
course so in three months of training
basically that's part of the vault you
get a little bit of this session you get
the rest of this session and everything
else so that's all in there but we also
have deeper training on YouTube on an
Instagram we have guest speakers we've
had Pat Flynn chalene johnson that come
in an inner circle we've had Mitch
Jackson the social media lawyer talking
about how to protect your ass it's how
do you protect your assets when it come
on right well when it comes to social
media protecting yourself legally and a
lot of again all the online business
type of content so if you're ready to
accelerate and grow your online business
faster if you're just starting out and
you want to have a shortcut and learn
from proven mentors on the think media
team
Heather tourists myself do a lot of does
a lot
training melissa Caputo Tony Arriola
and so it's amazing program so anyways
thinking or circle comm is where you can
learn more about that and let me know
your feedback in the comments or in the
iTunes review about a little bit of this
session of what you learn from Heather
Taurus with the seven elements of an
irresistible freemium oh hey it's time
for the comment of the week and this
week's comment comes from echo our sxj
it says content that will change your
life no joke it's that good everything
is well-executed the sound quality is on
point
with thoughtful and enriching questions
appreciate that I'm gonna keep reading
but just a quick shout out to a video
series on our think media channel all
about video podcasting if you want to
learn more about the microphones how we
do the video side how we organize all
the details of the think marketing
podcast we will link in the show notes a
link to our video podcasting series and
we I appreciate that feedback about
those details because we care about
those and we also have recommendations
for every budget we have invested quite
a bit into some of our gear but we've
got recommendations that are super
affordable whether you're just using
your phone or whether you want a fancy
setup like the one we use the review
continues I am for it I want more of it
if you're not convinced check out think
media YouTube channel that has over a
million subscribers and endless
high-quality content it will alter your
flip can existence wow your flip can't
existence no joke best for entrepreneurs
and people that want to tap into YouTube
vault of passive income or just express
themselves better using video and online
marketing happy listening will echo our
sxj appreciates you for the comment of
the week listen as we land the plane on
this week's think marketing podcast I
want to encourage you that in this
community we are hashtag action takers
look information is good it's super
important we need the best tips
strategies and tactics but it's actually
useless if we don't put it into
action so let me ask you a question what
is the next right step you need to make
to move your online business forward is
it to fix one of your free memes you
might say shoot after listening to
Heather my freemium is resistible like
it's very resistible I could see why
nobody signs up for it because it needs
to turn into an irresistible freemium by
applying these seven steps or maybe it's
not actually time for you to build an
email list right now because it might
not be the next right step maybe you
need to punch fear in the face and get
that next video out maybe you just need
to be taking action you know not over
optimizing at the start but just just
kind of start messy punch and fear in
the face punch and perfectionism in the
face and press and record I believe that
you know what the thing that maybe
you've been procrastinating the thing
that you've been putting off is come on
let's take action on that and if you
want to go deeper calendar block it
don't just write down the next to do the
next tip the net or the next thing you
need to actually do when are you gonna
do it like open Google Calendar open up
your planner and time block calendar
block when you're going to put that into
practice I want to encourage you I'm
just so grateful that you're part of
this community thank you for listening
if you if you would you know rate review
the podcast on itunes and wherever you
listen to this share this with somebody
because I know that right now whether
it's a business owner friend you know
whether it's a pastor of a church
whether it's somebody that is looking
for a way to make site income online
this pandemic that we've been going
through in 2020 which has been a crazy
year has actually shined a spotlight on
one thing that we know for sure video
matters live video matters podcasting
matters you gotta be leaning into social
those stats are real I'm reading it
right in front of my face right now on
video that the latest trends suggest
that more than half of the world's total
population will use social media by the
middle of the year that means right now
in 2020 when I'm recording this so it's
time to lean in it's time to punch fear
in the face and leverage video leverage
live-streaming leverage podcasting but
also be using it with the purpose and
building the eye
underneath the iceberg of an email list
so thanks for being a part of this
episode let's go take some action hit
the like button or share this wherever
you're listening or watching appreciate
you so much and we will see you in the
next episode of the think marketing
podcast peace